what do you think is the chance that our
universe was created by aliens in a lab
it's a possibility we don't understand
how the big bang came to exist uh and
it's really troubling that there was a
beginning in time uh and it's um in in a
way it shows the shortcoming of
Einstein's theory of general relativity
which has singularities and the Big Bang
is one of them it's it's a Time
Singularity if we go back in time there
was a point in time when uh the space
and time
you know had the Very extreme conditions
and and and we can't go beyond that
point and clearly the reason for that is
that there is no quantum mechanical
theory of gravity that is predictive the
you know for the past few decades there
were attempts to put these two theories
together of generativity and quantum
mechanics and I must say that despite
the the claims made by string theory is
they don't make any predictions about
the Big Bang they don't even make
predictions about what happens inside a
black hole so as far as I'm concerned
you know if you are a plumber and I ask
you can you fix my toilet and you say no
that's too difficult and I ask you okay
so can you fix uh
um my faucet and you say no that's also
too difficult
and then you tell me but actually in the
metaverse you know I'm a real plumber
that doesn't buy much for me I I would
say you're not a real plumber so
claiming that you're working on the
unification of quantum mechanics and
gravity and and you have some partial
success doesn't count if you can't solve
the main problems that face us and one
of them is how the big bang started and
I can imagine an advanced technological
civilization that has these two theories
unified because they had more than a
century of physics to work on and uh if
so they might engineer their knowledge
into creating a baby Universe in the lab
and of course our our universe could
have been the result of a lab experiment
and in that case it's just like humans
you know the babies grow up to become
adults and they have their own babies
and so forth so you can have a universe
inside of which the you know it gives
rise to technological civilizations that
give birth
to new baby universes and and it goes
forever this way so that's one
possibility and I consider it as
possible I suppose this would nicely
fold in the fine tuning argument as well
why is the cosmological constant just so
so delicately balanced along with
gravity along with the strong and weak
etc etc well I think it stems from the
fact that a very Advanced technological
civilization is a good approximation to
God
and of course some people believe that
God created the universe and I'm just
saying it could have been a
technological civilization that unified
quantum mechanics and gravity and then
the fine tuning is also argued oh well
there was a design here that some
numbers worked out so that we exist and
these numbers were designed by some
Divine entity well
you know here I say again whatever we
see around us including life could have
been
created by an advanced technological
civilization and the only way to find
out I mean the difference from religion
is that I'm talking about something that
can be tested experimentally if we find
evidence for such a civilization we will
know their capabilities I mean at some
point once we visit their home uh we can
see what they are up to or we might see
gadgets that are so Advanced that you
know we wouldn't be able to understand
that but and and they would be
considered as Miracles just the way
Moses you know in the Old Testament the
Bible Moses saw the burning bush and
that was a miracle that convinced Moses
that God exists well if I was around
Moses at the time I would use infrared
cameras that we are using right now in
in the Galileo project that I'm leading
and I could advise more Moses about the
the surface temperature of the burning
bush the amount of energy emitted period
of time and I could assess very clearly
whether the burning which is a natural
phenomena or some creation of a super
human entity so that he would you know
have more or less oh from this phenomena
and perhaps decide whether he believes
in in God or not but what I'm saying is
if a cave dweller came to New York City
right now the cave dweller would be at
all and would think that everything
around must be a miracle and that's what
Moses felt
you've talked about a number of Super
Advanced civilizations talk to me about
the different ways to classify
civilizations and their respective
usefulness
right so kardashev
Russian astronomer he
um classified civilizations based on the
amount of energy that they are
harvesting uh so right now we are using
up a small fraction of the energy from
the Sun uh that
is intercepted by Earth and you can
imagine like Freeman Dyson did the
surrounding the star with some Mega
structure that would Harvest all the
energy coming out of the star that's the
next step and kardashev even imagined
harvesting all the energy from all the
stars within our Milky Way galaxy and
that would be and of course one can even
think farther than that using all the
energy that the Universe the observable
universe creates
um but then that is
rather difficult engineering wise and
also I don't think it's the right skill
but you know it's not it's not a size
that matters let's put it that way in
terms of energy it's really what you do
with it and how you change your
environment and
um so obviously animals they adapt to
their environment whatever it is and as
humans we started changing the
environment climate change uh we created
the atomic bomb as Illustrated in their
recent film Oppenheimer you know that
was a major event because previously
uh you know nuclear energy was visible
to us in stars but was never used and
and once we started using it of course
it changed history change politics
change society
um and so the fact that we're able to
change nature as of now is quite
remarkable and you know we're making
substitutes to biological uh entities
like humans the human brain instead we
have the artificial intelligence that
could potentially surpass our abilities
mental abilities intellectual abilities
but uh one can eventually imagine us
changing environments on a bigger scale
and obviously the larger scale would be
to create a baby Universe in the
laboratory so I think that it's a much
more appropriate to evaluate the
abilities of or to gauge the
technological abilities of a
civilization by the way that it changes
everything around it uh ending up with
creating new universes
what do you make of the last few years
and specifically the last few months of
alien rumors what's what what do you
think is going on
well
um I should take responsibility for part
of the discussion here because
um uh about a couple of years ago I
created the Galileo project along with a
colleague of mine Frank laukian and
um that that was the result of my
previous book extraterrestrial where I
discussed the first reported
Interstellar object uh omuamua that was
discovered by telescope in Hawaii and uh
means that this word means Scout in the
Hawaiian language and at first everyone
thought it's a Rock From Another Star
but then it had anomalies it didn't look
like familiar rocks and it was flat in
its shape had an extreme uh shape and
moreover was pushed away from the Sun by
uh some mysterious Force without showing
any commentary of operation that could
give it the rocket effect so all
together it looked weird and I suggested
maybe it's pushed by reflecting sunlight
and actually three years later there was
an object discovered by the same
telescope in Hawaii that was pushed by
reflecting sunlight it ended up being a
rocket booster that was launched by NASA
in 1966
given the name 2020 so
and so
as a result of my book A lot of people
came to the porch of my home including
some multi-billionaires and they
provided me with funds
to establish the Galileo project a month
after the Director of National
Intelligence talked about unidentified
anomalous phenomena objects in the sky
that the government doesn't understand
and I actually met the Avril Haynes that
the Director of National Intelligence
and about half a year later at the
Washington National Cathedral and when
we were in The Green Room I said you
delivered this report and you have a
bachelor's degree in physics from
University of Chicago what do you make
of these objects that are not identified
and she said I don't know
and I believe her I think the government
is simply puzzled doesn't know and I'm
here to help them figure it out with the
Galileo project we have a functioning
Observatory at Harvard University and we
are planning to make copies of it and
place them in different locations and we
are basically observing the sky 24 7 uh
using infrared Optical radio and audio
sensors and then analyzing the data with
the machine learning artificial
intelligence to differentiate between
birds natural objects or balloons drones
airplanes human-made objects and we're
just checking if there's anything else
but as part of the Galileo project we
also have other branches one is to find
more objects like
that passed away from Earth and never
came very close
um and also to look for Interstellar
meteors these are object that came from
outside the solar system and collide
with Earth and I discovered the the
first such object from 2014 together
with my student Amir siraj and the
government confirmed this discovery and
I led an expedition
about a month and a half ago going to
the Pacific Ocean to the site of this
meteor and we did find some materials
that we're analyzing now and we can talk
more about it so that's my Approach
using the scientific method to answer a
question that I'm curious about that the
public is curious about and that the
government is curious about so I think
it's really inappropriate for scientists
to shy away from it to ridicule the
subject because science should serve
humanity and not just by building
nuclear bombs or nuclear reactors but
also by figuring out whether we have a
neighbor that's a fundamental question
that will change our future and
we can use the tools of science to
address this question not by waiting for
a phone call the way we did for seven
years waiting for a radio signal to be
transmitted in our Direction that's what
the city was all about
and surprisingly the city people are not
open-minded I mean they are really uh
upset that this line of research of
looking for objects is being taken that
I'm promoting it I'm not sure why you
know I came from a culture of cosmology
where for example the nature of most of
the matter in the universe is not known
it's called Dark Matter 83 percent of
the matter in the universe was never
seen in the solar system and so in that
culture if you suggest a possible
explanation to this puzzling data about
matter that we don't know it's nature
then people are encourage that because
then you can have experiments that test
that hypothesis it's part of doing
science however people that uh worked in
the context of seti for many years
looking for radio signals are upset that
there is another method which is looking
for objects in our backyard to check if
there is a tennis ball that the neighbor
may have been from that the neighbors
through in our Direction
um and I don't understand that I also
don't understand those people who worked
on stones in the sky for decades so
there are experts on meteor or
meteorites that are made of stone or or
iron at the very best iron meteorites uh
they basically argue that anything in
the sky must be Stone
and
what I say to that is that this
represents the Stone Age of science you
can't learn something new if you think
that everything in the sky must be Stone
it got to a point where the US
government reports data and they
confirmed it in a letter to NASA about
this meteor that I described from 2014
uh and you know they uh check the data
and they wrote an official letter to
NASA saying yes indeed as argues this is
of intestinal origin of the 99.99 and
yet a year later astronomers are you
know the government data is wrong by a
factor of three because otherwise we
can't fit the data with a stone
and I say you will never learn about
something new this way uh we know that
for example there is matter in the
universe that is not Stones it's called
Dark Matter we haven't seen it why not
be open-minded I mean uh yeah obviously
they feel threatened by Notions that you
know something else might be out there
why why Stone we we have there are many
many different elements we know that in
the heart of every Star that all of
these are created I I don't understand
what it threatens
for the current scientific establishment
if it wasn't Stone why have they hitched
themselves to this particular Stone
shaped wagon oh it's very simple because
if you say that the government data is
wrong by a factor three that this object
was moving three times slower than
claimed
and by the way I should say this is the
same government agency the U.S space
command that is monitoring the sky not
for meteors they are monitoring it for
ballistic missiles and if they would
make a mistake by a factor of three they
could tell the US president that there
is a missile heading towards Mexico
where it's actually headed towards
Washington DC I just think it's
completely irresponsible of astronomers
to argue that the main agency that is
funded as much as NASA or more actually
the U.S space command can make a mistake
by a factor of three after they wrote a
letter to NASA saying this is of
interstellar origin and
moreover the data originated from
satellites whereas the astronomers say
oh it probably came from a radar but it
was publicly shared that it came from a
satellite so you know it's actually
quite um insulting to say that to a
government agency that went beyond their
day job to confirm uh the identity of a
meteor just for the benefit of pure
science and another way to look at it is
I went there to their site in the
Pacific Ocean and amazingly I found
molten droplets from this object
concentrated along the meteor path that
they talked about the government talked
about so I sleep better at night because
I know that if there are ballistic
missiles ever launched towards the US
they would figure it out whereas my
colleagues would argue no they can get
it wrong all the time so then you know
what happens to these tens of billions
of dollars per year that are going in
their Direction like they are completely
fooling themselves if the astronomers
know that this this object must be Stone
so the point is the the argument is that
it's a factor of three slower therefore
it was actually not from outside the
solar system and only then can the data
be fitted with a model for a stone
because these are the most common rocks
that come from the sky there are
asteroids that belong to the solar
system and they are the most common
things you know there is only one I
still don't understand why they're so
bothered about it being Stone why
well that that's 95 percent of the rocks
that fall from the sky you know Are Made
of Stone okay and a five percent are
made of iron they are called iron
meteorites so
so they say we have a model that fits a
lot of data on these rocks okay and we
can fit the government data if the
government was wrong by a factor of
three in its speed then we can fit it
with a Stony meteorite that's what they
say and I say well actually I respect
the government data I respect data okay
I'm I'm not trying to be arrogant and
say oh the data must be wrong if my
model doesn't fit it I say I respect the
data because they checked it
and because I respect the data this
object could not have been a rock
now think about Voyager
um colliding with an exoplanet billions
of years from now we launched five
probes to Interstellar space over the
past five decades and one of them is
Voyager and it could collide with
another planet and then it would appear
as a meteor if the planet looks like the
Earth
and it has an atmosphere and oceans and
so forth and and obviously there you
would have those astronomers saying oh
no no the measurement was wrong it's
actually a rock but whoever respects the
data would say no it must be tougher
than the Rocks because it survived and
it was moving Faster by the way this
meteor moved faster than 95 percent of
all the stars in the vicinity of the sun
relative to the local frame of the Milky
Way galaxy and moreover it must have
been tougher than all the rocks that
were cataloged by NASA over the past
decade 272 of them and that's the way
that Voyager would appear That's why I
thought it's a possibility and they say
no it's not a possibility I say okay
well you write this paper now after I
came back from the site and I have the
spheroes in my hands you tell me there's
stones but I actually check their
composition on the ship at the time that
this paper was published and and
approved for publication by the way it's
not just the writers the authors it's
actually whoever reviewed it wanted it
to appear at the time that I'm coming
back and when I'm coming back I'm coming
with materials from this object and I
check them on the ship using an x-ray
fluorescence analyzer and I find that
they are mostly made of iron so
obviously not a stone and then there are
other elements in in the composition
that I I cannot mention because we are
now writing the paper on these findings
so what I'm saying is there are some
scientists
who declare that they are representing
science when they're actually violating
uh the the way science is done which is
follow the evidence so when the evidence
doesn't fit what they expect they would
argue the data must be wrong but then I
respect the data go there collect
materials from the path of the meteor
bring back the materials already knowing
that it's mostly iron and they publish a
paper exactly at the same time saying no
it's Stone and what can I say I have
respect for for the US government for
figuring it out because now I sleep
better at night and I'm not so worried
about ballistic missiles but this
astronomers must be really worried
serious serious drama going on in the
astronomy World okay so you go to this
site you find these spherials these tiny
tiny little balls you get to bring them
back you say that they have got a very
high iron content along with some of the
stuff that we can't talk about how do
you know that these little tiny little
balls are Interstellar objects how do
you know that they're not just something
that's been naturally created
terrestrially here on Earth well that's
what the paper will address but then I I
can tell you how in principle it can be
shown uh before that I just wanted to
mention uh you know after the sixth day
of the Expedition we found mostly I mean
we had a sled with magnets on it that
collected mostly volcanic ash and I
wrote 43 diary reports that were read by
millions all over the world and were
translated to Spanish people were
inspired to see how science is done so
the public appreciates that
um and then on the sixth day I basically
said where are the spirals because I
expected more than droplets to come off
the surface of the object when it was
exposed to the immense heat from the
fireball that it created as it moved
through air and there were a few percent
of the Hiroshima atomic bomb energy
released into 500 Kilograms so obviously
there should have been some molten
droplets and I wrote an essay saying
where are they we we haven't found them
yet and just to demonstrate to you that
when I don't find something I expect I
say that okay I uh I'm straightforward I
don't manipulate people in the case of
omuamua we didn't have enough data to
reach firm conclusions but I said maybe
it's of artificial origin it's a
possibility we should live on the table
that was the entire debate whether we
should leave it on the table or not here
I decided to take matters to my hand and
go and collect the materials so I can
figure it out and the when the
geologists of the team came a day later
after I wrote this essay came down the
stairs from the analysis room and said
Avi I was the chief scientist of the
mission he said Avi we found this feral
I immediately rushed up and looked at
the microscope and it was obvious you
could see this uh
spherical marble you know that
looked very distinct from the background
less than a millimeter in size
and I basically hugged the person next
to me who found it first and I said you
don't understand how
happy it makes me you know uh I'm so
happy it was something we you know it
was very challenging to find millimeter
size particles across the region that is
10 kilometers in size where the ocean
depth is two kilometers and finding it
with a sled that is just a meter in
width that has magnets on it is isn't a
remarkable achievement now to your
question so then I knew immediately we
will find more because I'm familiar with
what happens in the kitchen I wash
dishes every day that was their
agreement with my wife that's my duty at
home and when I see an ant I get alarmed
because I realize there must be many
more ants out there so when I saw the
first feral I said now we will find a
lot uh and indeed within hours we found
them more and over the
26 lines that we surveyed through this
region of 10 kilometers in size we found
the 50.
uh and then when we came back I have a
summer intern uh and she aspires to
become a science journalist but at some
point she said that her name is Sophie
Bergstrom she said that if I can be of
help let me know and I arranged for her
tweezers and microscope so she can go
over the materials once again and
because the the ship was Rocky and we
just didn't have enough time to go
carefully and so she went over the
materials and found 650 of them
so now we have more than 700 spherols
and that's amazing and then we could do
statistics
so to answer your question first thing
is we looked at the distribution of
spherols relative to the expected path
of the meteor
and there is a clear enhancement along
the path of the meteor relative to the
background okay so that's Point number
one point number two we can now take
those ferals each of them is a milligram
roughly and analyze them using a mass
spectrometer try to figure out their
composition
and that includes two aspects one is
elements from the periodic table we can
ask is the abundance of elements similar
to solar system materials and just to
remind you the solar system formed out
of a cloud of gas that was enriched by
an exploding star nearby a supernova and
it gave it roughly the same abundance of
heavy elements
and so you know the solar system when it
was made was roughly of the same
composition
and in fact there are some
elements that have very precise values
in their abundances and what we can do
is check whether the the the spherols
have the same abundances along the
meteor path and then of course when we
deviate from the meteor path go far away
they should have the solar system
abundances
and that's something we can check and we
are already checking we already have
some data I cannot speak about it and
then the second thing we can do and we
already did is check Isotopes
radioactive isotopes these are elements
that have a finite lifespan and you can
think of them as
time bombs they they exist for a period
of time and they have a half-life and
you can use them as clocks they Decay
into daughter products and you can
compare the abundance of these parent
Isotopes to the daughter products and
figure out
uh the age of the material again we can
compare it to the age of the solar
system so there is a very simple and
straightforward way of telling apart any
material you find
compare relative to the solar system and
of course until now all the rocks that
fell from the sky were from the solar
system you know because this is the
first identified Interstellar meteor
it's the first one where we knew that
it's Interstellar came from outside the
sources because of its high speed it was
more you know we translated the speed
near the Earth to the speed that it had
far away and it was moving at 60
kilometers per second outside of the
solar system it was faster than nearby
Stars 95 percent of them outside the
solar system so it was really fast and
if it were to collide with Earth head on
as the Earth moves around the Sun it
would have had a relative speed of 90
kilometers per second however it came
from behind the Earth so it had only 45
kilometers per se so anyway
um when such an object passes through
Earth through the atmosphere of Earth uh
it loses some
elements and that is called
fractionation and just by examining the
spherols you can also distinguish
between materials that came from Earth
itself geological activity and materials
that came through the air at a high
speed because evaporation
removes some of those and some of the
elements and and so what I'm saying is
that there are signatures of both a
meteor passing through the atmosphere
and moreover a signature of materials
associated with that meteor
that came from outside the solar system
because if it came from far away it was
exposed to a different Supernova a
different exploding star and different
different abundances of elements
presumably this means that it could just
be a normal meteor
from outside of the solar system it
doesn't necessarily mean that it's an
alien artifact that it's a voyager probe
but from some other star system okay so
here we get to the second question
uh the second question is is it
technological in origin how can we
address that well imagine Voyager
entering the Earth's atmosphere at 45
kilometers per second and appearing as a
meteor just
given its path it could happen in a few
billionaires that it will collide with
an Earth-like planet okay and then
imagine the surface of this
Voyager meteor
melted as a result of the friction with
the air
and creating spherols obviously their
composition let's say of stainless steel
would appear different than a rock okay
and imagine uh melting the surface of a
computer screen or melting
semiconductors obviously you'll have
some rare elements that appear at much
higher abundance than you find in nature
so there are ways of telling something
technological because you can see some
pattern of elements that you wouldn't
find under a natural setting uh in
nature so uh that's the second question
that we want to address and of course
that would be a dramatic
realization if true but even if we just
find it to be a rock from another planet
far away near another star very far away
very different from Earth that is a
historic Discovery because it's the
first time that humans put their hands
on the materials from a large object
that came from outside the solar system
and we will have confirmation from two
directions one is the speed of the
object which some of my colleagues
dismiss and say the government measured
it wrong but completely independently if
we see that the composition of the
materials is not solar system material
then
um you know that's obviously
an independent piece of evidence telling
us that it came from far away it's
Interstellar which happens to be the
title of my book Interstellar so let's
see what happens so that's us detecting
using uh experimental design in order to
be able to search for out there and also
detect samples of materials that are
from different star systems let's get on
to us us as Humanity
if it's the case that we are on a very
long but still ticking down clock to
where the ultimate global warming is
going to occur when the sun expands
right like global warming is happening
regardless of how vehement you disagree
with the levels of sea temperature
because over a long enough time the
sun's going to engulf us all that means
that we need to get off Planet
eventually
in your opinion what are some of the
most promising ways that we could travel
across Interstellar distances what have
you what have you sort of thought about
when it comes to this right so first I
should say that irrespective of what we
do about our own industrial pollution
and global warming that we trigger by
our Technologies uh there will be an
inevitable global warming that will
basically boil off the oceans and that
will happen in about a billion years
because the sun is getting
uh brighter and the calculations of the
evolution of the sun imply that uh there
would be
um
uh boiling of the ocean as a result of
um the interplay between the Earth's
atmosphere and the and the ground and
um so um we don't have more than 20
percent of the lifespan of Earth
to continue Life as we know it okay and
we will and and it's you know most of
the stars formed billions of years
before the sun and uh therefore stars
like the sun with planets like the Earth
already went through that a lot of them
billions of those and we probably didn't
hear the cries for help from those
civilizations who decided to stay on the
planet it was the biggest item in the
news reports not so much the the global
warming they make as a result of the
Technologies if they happen to overcome
that it was the fact that they they just
sit at a fixed distance from their star
and the furnace is getting hotter so you
have to move out but you can't and we if
you are stuck to the planet and perhaps
they had some major Exodus in spacecraft
leaving the planet that we are not aware
of there must have been a lot of
tragedies that's what I'm trying to say
over a cosmic history we just tend to
think about stars and say look these
Stars evolve in this way in that way
based on the physics we know but we are
missing
the human perspective of just imagine
the star evolving in the way that we
expect it to how many tragedies of other
cultures other technological
civilizations happen in the Milky Way
galaxy alone and then you know now there
are these uh
completely
desert-like surfaces of planets that
used to have Life as we know it and it's
really tragic we a lot was lost over
Cosmic history now if you ask me what
would the future hold so
actually frankly I'm very proud of our
technological kids okay which at this
time are the artificial intelligence
systems that we are developing and they
are growing in their capabilities
exponentially so it's possible that by
the end of this decade they would
surpass by a large margin uh the human
brain okay and I'm proud of that I don't
see that as a threat because it's not
obvious to me that biological creatures
like ourselves are any different than um
the Primitive uh you know single cell
organisms that were on Earth to start
with and they were replaced by more
advanced uh entities and so perhaps we
are just one phase in the evolution and
ultimately it will be all about
artificial intelligence and
self-replicating probes that are not
biological okay we we of course learn
from nature we are trying to replicate
the human brain we're trying to make 3D
printers that will produce
three-dimensional objects we haven't yet
produced a self-replicating car you know
a car even a car that can repair itself
like the human body that you put a
banded Aid on it after an accident and
it will repair itself we don't have that
and it will take us a little while but
then
ultimately you know we will get to the
point where artificial intelligence
carries the torch of intelligence at
least here on Earth and I believe that
it should do so also in space because
when you send the probe to Interstellar
distances it would take Millions to
billions of years for it to reach any
destination and and that means thousands
of light years away and any such prob
cannot wait for guidance from the
senders it will take thousands of years
for a one-way communication signal and
so they need to have their brain if you
want them to function when they reach
their destination obviously artificial
intelligence is a better path forward
than biological brains because they're
very vulnerable biology is very
vulnerable to cosmic rays you know you
can't survive in space for more than a
few years exposed to cosmic rays even if
you were a spacesuit
um and that's one problem by in going to
Mars that doesn't have an atmosphere we
would need to go into caves in into lava
tubes to be protected from cosmic rays
but moreover human lifespan is very
limited and this would be millions
billions of years so it's much better to
send technological gadgets potentially
that would self-replicate and that's the
way I see it uh now they will carry uh
whatever
uh you know tasks we provide them with
maybe we can ask them to replicate what
we care about here so instead of sending
what we have here uh by biology the way
we have it we can perhaps
have them see the biology over at Great
distances by using the raw materials on
a planet that appears to be habitable or
create whatever we feel like out there
and to me that's that's the best path
forward sending the type of equipment
that can carry
the intellectual DNA the whatever we
care about
um elsewhere and reproduce it wherever
we want it if we want to replicate it so
that we have many copies of it now of
course in the solar system we might
bring people to the moon to the to to
Mars
um and then it would be interesting to
establish colonies there but this is not
really going very far from the sun and
it would not solve the long term
issue of longevity
so I do believe in technology leading
the way and of course if we find that
someone else did it already that would
Inspire us that would give us a glimpse
at our technological future that's why
you know I was actually I'm jogging
every morning at Sunrise and I did so
also on the ship that was fittingly
called Silver Star and I had a filming
crew with me and you know there were 50
filmmakers and producers and directors
that contacted me they wanted to be on
the ship and I selected one but the
director of that filming crew he decided
to uh fill me one morning on the deck of
the ship when I was jogging and he said
to me either you are running are you
running away from something or towards
something
and I told him I'm running away from
some of my colleagues
who have very strong opinions without
seeking evidence
and I'm running towards a higher
intelligence in interstellar space
yes so what you're suggesting
is
it seems it seems like you you think it
would be unlikely
for a human or a Generation ship of a
series of humans to go from Earth to
some other star system like let's say
Proxima Centauri Alpha Centauri Etc
you think it's much more likely much
more feasible to go artificial
intelligence put it on a ship maybe have
a desktop encoder for bioengineering or
something like that it's got the code it
gets there it then deploys the code I
think
I I understand how you could see that as
a solution uh I don't think that that's
going to satisfy most people's feeling
or their desire for human civilization
to continue it will not satisfy most
people's desires but just think about a
dandelion flower
okay what does a dandelion do
it sends off seeds that are carried by
the wind
and they carry the DNA of the dandelion
flower and establish new flowers
now you might say oh that's not
satisfactory because as a dandelion
flower I really want to be out there in
other places
but no
that's not what nature what nature cares
about is longevity of information
content and in the case of the dandelion
flower it's not the identity of the
single dandelion actually for humans as
well you know all of us die right so we
we have kids that carry our DNA we gave
up on us living forever or some people
didn't give up but we don't have an
option okay let's put it that way and
what I'm saying is if you think about it
more broadly it's not so much about
yourself as an individual
uh it's about maintaining
longevity of the what you care about uh
and the dandelion flowers I mean at
least from the point of view of biology
cares about having more dandelion
flowers like it preserving the beauty of
the dandelion flower and therefore it
doesn't have any umbilical cord
connecting it to the seeds you might say
if it wanted it could have been
connected to the cities no but that
doesn't work very well because then you
need a long wire that goes all the way
to where the seed lands on the floor uh
and only then the dandelion will learn
something about what this the
whereabouts of the seeds but in the way
that nature does it it just sends the
seeds with the wind and they do their
job and sort of there is some trust in
the system so in the same way that you
send a spacecraft with AI
somewhere and you don't communicate with
it because it takes a long time it's
very cumbersome for the for you to
communicate with it you just trust it it
will do the job and that's the way
nature works
do you think that we will ever
physically visit another galaxy whether
that be an AI robot whether that be a
spacecraft that has the seeds of our
Noah's Ark spacecraft Noah's Ark
um obviously
I'm aware that we're talking about oh my
God we found something from outside of
the solar system and I'm saying why
don't we take it one step further and
get outside of the Galaxy but what do
you think is is that something that's
realistic could we get when the Milky
Way to elsewhere here is a fact of life
that we need to accept that the universe
is not just expanding
its expansion is accelerating
and that means that any distant Galaxy
beyond the local group of galaxies the
ones surrounding the Milky Way any
Galaxy farther away than a few million
light years
uh is running away from us at an ever
increasing speed
and once the universe will age by a
factor of
10. all these galaxies will recede away
from us faster than the speed of light
so even if you build the fastest
spacecraft that moves at the speed of
light you won't be able to catch up with
them
and if you ask me there is only one
galaxy outside the Milky Way that we
have a chance of getting to
I mean we could aim to get to more but
that would require proportionate speeds
that are getting close to the speed of
light but the one that we have a good
chance of getting to is the one that
will collide with the Milky Way and
merge with it that's a cheat that I knew
you were going to give that answer and
that's cheating we can't we can't wait
for Andromeda to come to us that's not
the same thing that I meant so I
actually did a calculation and asked
them suppose you move
uh you know at
a higher speed than chemical Rockets how
far can we go okay and if you have a
spacecraft that moves 10 times faster
you can go within the so-called Virgo
cluster of galaxies that's within a
distance of some tens of millions of
light years we can do that
but you need the propulsion scheme that
uh is 10 to 100 times faster 100 times
would buy us that uh
otherwise it's just um you know the the
universe expansion is too rapid uh so I
can imagine us getting to other galaxies
as long as we can make our propulsion
let's say a hundred times faster than
all the spacecraft that we launched so
far and of course there is a benefit to
that because then we can all settle in a
bigger environment like the center of
the vehicle cluster includes the the
Galaxy m87 which is a giant elliptical
galaxy and there are many more stars
there uh than the Milky Way has by a
factor of about a hundred so um uh you
know we will just have a bigger party
over there as the rest of the universe
recedes away from us more resources and
actually I had a correspondence with
Freeman Dyson about a decade ago on this
subject because
um
what I pointed out is that as the
universe is accelerating you know we
will be left in a lonely place and he
said why don't we contact all these
other civilizations out there far away
and arrange a project of cosmic
engineering where all of us will come
together by moving Our Stars with us and
I said that's too much work I mean we
can do much better by just simply going
to a cluster of galaxies like the Virgo
cluster and finding you know hundreds or
maybe thousands of times more stars in
our environment
and instead of us moving stars we can
just go to where the stars are which are
clusters of a cluster of galaxies nearby
okay so this is this is kind of the same
as Cosmic fertile ground so to speak
yeah so I know that you mentioned about
how galaxies are moving apart they're
going to move apart they're ever ever
increasing speeds is the Virgo cluster
even though they are distinct individual
galaxies are they sufficiently gravity
bound that that's going to stick
together that's not going to blow apart
will stick together but if we don't go
there it's going to go away to move away
from us so what we need is to go there
and then we'll have uh you know the
company of let's say a thousand times
more stars than the Milky Way has so um
you might imagine a situation where we
are not the first to recognize that that
in fact other civilizations decided to
do that and then you have a flow of
these spacecraft towards the center of
the vehicle cluster right now because
everyone recognizes that they want to be
there to raise to the fertile ground
well I would call it the cosmic party
where you can celebrate until you EXO
until the the lights
go down and the lights the lights will
go down if you ask me when would that
happen that would happen uh when the
smallest stars will burn up their fuel
which will happen when the universe will
age by another factor for almost a
thousand uh so in 10 trillion years
that's when the tiniest Stars will go
away and those are the most common Stars
so we are fortunate the nearest star to
the sun is actually a dwarf star Proxima
Centauri and it would live for trillions
of years you know the sun will die
at an age of one percent of that so um
so it's a hundred it will have a hundred
times longer life span and obviously if
you want to uh get the light from a
nuclear furnace like this like a star
then we want to come close to a dwarf
star like Proxima centaurian and
amazingly it has a planet in the
habitable zone but then you might ask
why are we close to a star that is not
typical if most of the stars are dwarfs
why do we reside next to the Sun and
there might be a reason for that because
these furnaces the dwarf stars you know
they're much
uh fainter because they have less fuel
but and they burn it more slowly than
the Stars like the Sun so in order to
keep yourself warm you need to get
closer to them in the case of Proxima
Centauri you need to get 20 times closer
that's where the habitable zone is and
then when you are so close to a star you
are vulnerable to the eruptions on the
star the flares and those can remove the
atmosphere of habitable planets so it's
possible that
the best place is uh being close to to a
star like the Sun but obviously you know
in the future the sun will not stay
around and we would we could create our
own nuclear energy you know we can use a
nuclear reactor to provide all of our
energy needs well my favorite Theory one
of my favorite theories about far-flung
future civilizations
uh it is the idea that we would wait
until you get really close to heat death
of the universe because it's then very
very cold which means that if you want
to run computer systems they can burn
off all of their heat as a byproduct of
that they can be kept cool they can run
more efficiently you're now doing
simulations within simulations within
simulations of you and all of your
ancestors and it's this blissed out
completely perfect world that you want
to exist in or whatever artificially
recreated consciousness
you can do that much more easily when
the universe is much cooler so yes you
have a you have an energy problem
because you no longer have as much
energy that you have access to but I've
seen a number of theories that talk
about almost going into hibernation
super Advanced civilizations going into
hibernation capturing energy or finding
a way to create their own energy for as
long as they need to and then switching
off or going into standby mode waiting
for the universe to get down to a
requisite cool temperature
I mean this is um similar to
um you know some people as they get old
they go on a diet that keeps them more
healthier so they can live longer but of
course the best way to prolong the
longevity of your DNA is to have a lot
of kids that will have more kids that
will have more kids rather than you uh
and so here I come back to the idea that
if we you know by that time it's quite
likely that whoever is around will
figure out how to make baby universes
and by creating baby universes can
basically put whatever you want in those
babies in terms of their qualities such
that you will know that life will
continue in them have you thought about
how long the
average civilization that doesn't become
Interstellar would exist for obviously
that that depends a lot on how
intelligent they are because if you look
at what we do
we spend two trillion dollars every year
on Military budgets uh we are thinking
about how to kill other people or how to
protect ourselves from being killed you
know that that was the true you know
when we were in the jungle you know and
had the to survive in zero-sum games
it's not true anymore we could have
worked together uh instead of conquering
small pieces of land and being proud of
that uh you know we're talking about
um you know the the surface of this rock
that we happen to be born on like why is
that so valuable uh why do we need to
feel Superior relative to other people
just for superficial reasons like the
color of their skin or their ethnic
origin I mean this is completely
ridiculous if you think about it from a
perspective of intelligence yet we spend
two trillion dollars a year on that now
imagine if we were you know if we were
to find them as sign of a cosmic
neighbor and we will tell ourselves wait
a minute that makes no sense you know
look at this other civilization they
live much longer look at the
Technologies they develop why aren't we
having a different set of priorities and
and then we will remember the words of
the song by John Lennon who said imagine
all the people living in peace and we
would say oh yeah that's a good idea
let's live in peace and let's use then
we will have a a surplus two trillion
dollars a year what can we do with it uh
we can use it for space exploration and
I did the calculation I did the math and
with that budget we can send a probe to
every star in the Milky Way galaxy by
the end of this century
billions of probes by the end of this
Century sending them of course it will
take them time to get there you know
maybe billions of years but we can just
do that now imagine a a another
civilization who reached this conclusion
they have their own John Lennon they got
their own inspiration they're more
intelligent than we are they are not
wasting resources on fighting each other
and conquering a small piece of land on
this rock that they were born on okay
they instead they say let's work
together rather than kill each other
let's not feel Superior relative to each
other let's Thrive towards uh a better
future so Prosperity is recognized as a
priority rather than zero-sum games
and imagine them sending props
everywhere and then these props make
their way and by the way uh the speed of
those probes that we send so far is at
least 10 times smaller than the speed
needed to escape from the gravitational
pull of the Milky Way galaxy so
if if others send probes like that they
would keep accumulating in the Milky Way
galaxy over Cosmic time and over
billions of years so just like Plastics
in the ocean and many of those will not
be functional anymore just imagine you
know Voyager a billion years for now it
will not be working it will just paste
trash and just like Plastics in the
ocean it's trash but it keeps
accumulating
and the same would happen with all these
probes that's what I'm talking about
let's check out backyard and see if
there is a tennis ball thrown by a
neighbor right we have the difficulties
that are facing going
Interstellar pale in insignificance in
the different difficulties going into
galactic
one thing that I was really interested
by no matter what the spacecraft is
let's say that it was seeded with a
tabletop bioengineering 3D printer that
can recreate human babies in a test tube
or something
can you just talk me through the Journey
pick any star that you want pick any
star that you think looks like a nice
piece of real estate within the Milky
Way galaxy can you just explain what the
major hurdles upon that Interstellar
Journey would consist of I know we've
got the Oort cloud we've got different
things that we need to get through like
what are the what are the main hurdles
that we need to get past right so first
I should say that even biology we should
not dismiss it all together because just
recently there were some worms found in
the uh in the Siberian permafrost and
then they were frozen and after they
were rejuvenated in the laboratory they
came to life 46
000 years
after they became Frozen 46 000 years so
one can imagine engineering biology
perhaps to survive Interstellar travel
that that is something for the future
um so we don't yet know if it's possible
but it may be but then in terms of the
timetable
um so let's imagine the kind of
spacecraft we are launching right now
because that's what we are doing I mean
I of course am leading a very ambitious
initiative called star show to launch a
spacecraft at the fifth of the speed of
light to the nearest star it will take
20 years but we are not there yet the
technology is very challenging so let's
um imagine chemical Rockets of the type
that we used
um and so a chemical rocket just like
Voyager One Voyager two Pioneer 10
Pioneer 11 and New Horizons that are
making their way out of the solar system
so these were launched over the past 50
years okay so they are still deep in
inside the solar system the solar system
by the way the old cloud is a hundred
thousand times larger than the Earth's
sun separation okay so these uh
spacecraft will exit we'll get to the
outskirts of the solar system the edge
of the old cloud
which is by the way halfway to the
nearest star Proxima Centauri they will
get there uh within about ten thousand
twenty thousand years depending on which
spacecraft you are talking about
um uh so we're talking tens of thousands
of years
okay they will not be functional we may
be gone by then that's another lesson
that you can look for packages in your
mailbox while the sender is dead
that's the advantage of of that compared
to the method of City to look for a
phone call to search for someone sending
you a radio signal it needs to be active
so here you know we might be dead by the
time our packages leave the solar system
at least the ones that we send so far
and if we send something much faster in
the future it will overtake those very
slow ships that sail through space
um okay so after 10 000 years we leave
the solar system we start making our way
into into this is truly Interstellar
space at that point because we cross the
midpoint separating us from the nearest
star okay and then to get to the nearest
star we're taking uh some more tens of
thousands of years because we cross the
midpoint uh so we're talking tens of
maybe 50 000 years to reach the nearest
star
and that is roughly the time that
elapsed since the first humans left
Africa
okay just think about it if we were to
send a spacecraft when the first humans
left Africa it would get
to the nearest star just now
and then
if we continue to The Voyage Through
space how long will it take us to go to
the other side of the Milky Way galaxy
that will take us half a billion years
so it sounds long but it actually
is not so long because the time
difference between the formation of most
stars and the formation of the sun is
billions of years most stars formed
billions of years before the Sun so
there was enough time even for chemical
Rockets to make their way to our
doorstep but that's um and and at that
speed we can't really exit the solar
system as you can tell because the edge
of the solar system is another factor of
10 farther away and that would make the
travel time equal to the age of the
universe and you mean the edge not the
edge of the solar system the edge of the
Galaxy you mean
sorry then yeah the the time to cross
the age of the Milky Way galaxy would be
longer than the age of the universe yes
okay and because it's ten times bigger
than the Milky Way disc that I was
alluding to before going to a star on
the other side of the Milky Way galaxy
so there is the entire hello of dark
matter of the Milky Way which is 10
times bigger or even more 20 times
bigger than the extent of the disk of
stars that are at this near the center
of the Milky Way galaxy so actually if
you think of galaxies there is the
Luminous part
which is sort of like a light bulb in
the middle but then there is this big
structure that is invisible to us of
dark matter that is 20 times bigger
what is your proposed propulsion
mechanism to get to
the the nearest closest star at
one-fifth the speed of light
oh that is using a light sail basically
a very thin membrane that's the concept
of the Starship project
uh if this membrane weighs about a gram
if it has the size of a person roughly
and it's being pushed by a very powerful
laser 100 gigawatt laser for a few
minutes it would reach a fifth of the
speed of light and you can put in this
light cell you can put some electronic
uh
infrastructure that could record for
example take a photograph when it comes
close to the
planet near Proxima Centauri and also
transmit the signal to us that is not so
much of a challenge the big challenge is
generating this Photon engine the
radiation that uh associated with the
laser such that you have a beam of light
focused on the sail and pushing it uh
the sale itself can be made of materials
that we already know and that it could
be sufficiently tough
the main challenge is getting it to
maintain a stable ride on the Light Beam
with a very powerful laser and then
communicating whatever it finds uh near
the planet around Proxima centaurian I
should say that it takes a few minutes
to get it to a fifth of the speed of
light then it continues the travel like
a bullet to towards the destination that
will take 20 years at the fifth of the
speed of light so it's two minutes of
very fast acceleration and then coasting
over 20 years before it gets to the
destination
that's right you need a lot of patience
that's all I'm saying well you need a
little bit of patience you need a lot
more accuracy I think that's the main
that's the main thing yeah so one other
thing that I was thinking about it seems
to me
it's probably disheartening to hear that
you know there isn't going to be a human
or it seems unlikely in your estimation
that a human will go to some other
system that it's it's likely to be
seeded by whatever whatever well I would
not really doubt by the way if you go
through the numbers
if we develop this technology of light
sales and you get to the extreme of
using all the energy intercepted by
Earth
from sunlight you know uh and you use
all that energy
to create a very powerful radio beam
that is pushing a sale a giant sale this
time it could propel
humans at an acceleration of 1G
for about a year
and if you accelerate at one G for one
year you can reach the speed of light
wow and that is possible in principle
and we would not feel any different than
being on Earth because gravity gives us
an acceleration of 1G on the surface of
Earth so if you board a spacecraft that
is accelerated accelerating at one G it
would feel just like being on the
surface of Earth
and the only issue is how to build such
the infrastructure necessary to use all
the power coming from the Sun on Earth
towards creating a giant radio beam that
pushes on a light sail but in principle
I did the calculation it's possible is
there not a second problem which is how
do you slow down
oh for that you need a similar Beam on
the other end but if you just get to the
speed by the way if you bought such a
ship and you continue accelerating at
one G for 20 years
you can cross the entire universe
while the universe is aging
but because of time dilation according
to Einstein's special theory of
relativity you can do it in your
lifetime so the only problem there is
that you need a huge amount of power to
keep accelerating for 20 years at 1G but
I thought you wanted to go quicker than
the speed of light
you cannot well according to what we
know in physics we cannot go faster than
light but you don't need to you just
need to go very close to the speed of
light and then time is ticking more
slowly in your spacecraft than it is in
elsewhere so the universe you know will
age by billions of years while you are
aging just by a decade
and because you're getting so close to
the speed of light of course there are
lots of practical problems how to get
enough power to propel you at 1G for
such a long period of time also when
you're moving so fast any particle of
dust or any material that you collide
with Will generate a huge explosion on
your ship
yeah very good I saw a
visual representation a computer
simulation of what it would be like to
approach the speed of light from the
front deck of a ship and all manner of
weird stuff starts happening the way
that the light moves past you and
doesn't
um it's very very bizarre by the way
that is the best way to maintain
longevity when the universe ages by
billions of years you are just aging by
decades just move fast move faster yeah
just move fast and of course then if you
have a similar system elsewhere you can
slow down the the problem is you need
someone else to build it
um so um otherwise you will just move at
that speed for a very long time
um of course this is you know this is
science we are not I mean there are
practical problems but it's all Allowed
by the laws of physics I don't like
science fiction because it violates the
laws of physics the the storyline very
often
Avi lobe ladies and gentlemen Avi I
really appreciate your work I'm very
excited to see what you come up with on
this new paper what you can reveal to
the world once you've finally got your
work done and got it past everything and
I'm interested to see what other groups
of people and colleagues you can piss
off as you continue to to do your
research where should people go if they
want to keep up to date with all of the
stuff that you're talking about and
Publishing and all the rest yeah I just
wanted to comment on what you said the
footnote that uh you know we know that
we are not at the center of the universe
and we also know that humans came to
exist only over the past few million
years so if you come to a play a cosmic
play in this case you are not at the
center of the stage and you're coming at
the end of the play the play is not
about you
and the best way to find out what it's
about is to look for other actors and
ask them
so that's what I'm trying to do
um in terms of my writings I have essays
on medium.com and you can just type
avilo at medium.com where you can find
updates about my research also I have a
website on at Harvard University that
you can go to the professional website
where you can see some links to papers
and videos and interviews and other
things and I have no footprint
whatsoever on social media because you
know I just realized that if you want an
airplane to fly faster you reduce the
friction with air you reduce its
cross-sectional area so I reduce my
friction to the best of my ability with
other people who may criticize me may
want to slow me down I simply don't have
any footprint on social media another
metaphor that I should mention in this
context
there is the metaphor of The Crow and
the Eagles so the crow is the only bird
that can sit on the Eagle's back and
pick at the Eagle's neck and there are
photographs of crows on the backs of
eagles but the Eagles do not waste any
energy or effort pushing the crows
away
uh what they do is rise to Greater
Heights where the oxygen level is low
and the crows just drop off they're back
to me the the greatest height is to do
my science in the best possible way by
collecting evidence material evidence
and studying it and reaching my
conclusions based on what the evidence
shows and once I get to those Heights
all the crows that are currently pecking
at my neck will drop off
what a mic drop Avi I really appreciate
you thank you mate if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe